how come netflix canceled your show I
mean I know it's a good show wasn't
about that is it that is it hard to do
topical stuff on that platform I think
it's because again I don't think they
like my sweaters but no I mean obviously
Netflix has trained their viewers to pin
your watch and we actually tried that as
well but yeah I mean so far they have
not why I mean so far people you know
aren't watching Netflix that way I was
hoping you know ours would be the first
but you know they gave me 19 shots and
all you know I was very happy to do it
and because there they are the king of
the world right now so believe me I was
very happy about the opportunity but I
would like to know if you guys have any
jobs for me what seems like you've
always got you're always working like
another thing you have Caroline's this
weekend you have a movie coming out you
know you're in the happy time murders
movie do you or do you kind of always
like to have something couple things
going yes I mean I'm a desperate
workaholic and I I've always lived but
like when I was 14 I was washing dishes
and delivering newspapers and dealing
cocaine I just a lot of young and that's
how I could always look at that being in
our business it's always hustling so I
don't ever want to have to get a real
job so I'm all my wife is like can you
slow down a little bit I'm like yeah
just a second and I'll be back in two
days after I go to boxing Mississippi to
do yeah more comedy so I've always I
always am kind of hustling to see what
the next thing is you end my life so is
the silver lining to the Netflix show
being done that you don't have to watch
all the bad TV what while you're not
doing a soup type show do you get to
just ignore all the nonsense television
that you normally have to cover it is
yes it's a blessing and a curse
because some of those
some of those shows are hard to get
through definitely I mean I god bless
handy Colin and the Empire he's built
but some of those Real Housewives Jos
making me want to pull my eyes out
because I go I wonder if they're gonna
get drunk and fight in this episode oh
it happened to get so yeah I mean it's a
bit though I some of the stuff that we
found from around the world was really
fun and like like what does it love
Island that show that's taking over all
of Europe or the Jersey Shore spin-offs
yeah like Warsaw shore near the shore
so that that sort of stuff I kind of
took great Glee and but but so know now
I can go back to you know am I really
getting through all my Dostoevsky books
but yeah I would
I'm sure hopefully there'll be another
opportunity somewhere around to to make
fun of those again but who knows one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]